WORK.
THANK GOD FOR THAT.
SHELBY STEELE, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: TONY KENNETT IS THE
SCIENCE COORDINATOR AT THE
INDIANAPOLIS SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
INDIANA AND THE AUTHOR OF
CHALKBOARD REVIEW.
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN HIS VIDEO
MAKING THE ROUNDS ON THE
INTERNET TODAY.
IN THE VIDEO, KENNETT RESPONSE
TO CLAIMS FROM DEMOCRATS THAT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY ISN'T
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS, WATCH.
>> WE DO HAVE CRITICAL RACE
THEORY AND HOW WE TEACH.
WE TELL OUR TEACHERS TO TREAT
STUDENTS DIFFERENTLY BASED ON
COLOR.
WE TELL OUR STUDENTS THAT EVERY
PROBLEM AS A RESULT OF WHITE MEN
AND THAT EVERYTHING WESTERN
CIVILIZATION BUILT IS RACIST.
CAPITALISM IS A TOOL OF WHITE
SUPREMACY.
THOSE ARE STRAIGHT OUT OF
KIMBERLY CRENSHAW'S WRITINGS,
VERBATIM, THE WRITINGS THAT
FORMED THE MOVEMENT.
THIS IS IN SCIENCE, HISTORY, THE
ARTS, AND IT IS NOT SLOWING
DOWN.
>> Jesse: TONY KENNETT JOINS
US NOW.
YOU ARE SAYING -- YEAH, THEY
DON'T HAVE CRT 101 AFTERMATH
CLASS, BUT WHAT THEY DO HAVE IS
THE ENTIRE CRT INFUSED IN EVERY
SINGLE COURSE AND EVERY SINGLE
CLASSROOM THROUGHOUT THE
CURRICULUM, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE IS THIS A VERY CLEVER
TRICK THAT A LOT OF
ADMINISTRATORS WILL PULL.
IN EDUCATION, THE RHETORICAL
THINGS THAT CONSIST OF WHAT
LEARNING.
CURRICULUM, WHICH IS WHAT THE
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING, AND THEN
PEDAGOGY, WHICH IS HOW IT IS
TAUGHT.
SO WE CAN OFFICIALLY TELL
PARENTS, WE ARE NOT TEACHING
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
IT IS NOT AN INDIANA ACADEMIC
STANDARDS, BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THE CLASSROOM DOOR SHUTS, AND
THE TEACHER STARTS TEACHING
THROUGH A LENS OF THIS RACE
ESSENTIALISM THAT PITS STUDENTS
AGAINST EACH OTHER BASED ON
THEIR COLOR.
>> Jesse: SO GIVE ADVICE TO
PARENTS OUT THERE.
PERHAPS THEY DON'T KNOW IF CRT
IS IN THE SCHOOL THAT THEIR KIDS
ARE GOING TO.
HOW WOULD THEY GO ABOUT
DISCOVERING IT?
AND IF IT IS INFECTED IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE THEY LIVE,
WHAT IS THEIR NEXT STEP?
>> WELL, THE FIRST THING YOU
SHOULD BE DOING IS TALKING TO
YOUR KIDS TEACHERS.
SO MANY OF MY PARENTS HAD GREAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH ME WEEKLY ON
WHAT WAS GOING ON NOT JUST
INSIDE MY CLASSROOM BUT INSIDE
THE SCHOOL.
THERE IS THIS VERY INTERESTING
MYTH BY THE LEFT THAT ALL OF THE
TEACHERS ARE ON THE LEFT, AND
THE RIGHT BELIEVES THAT.
A LOT OF TEACHERS REALLY JUST
WANT TO GO IN AND TEACH AND ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
PARENTS.
HOWEVER, IF YOU FIND THAT A
TEACHER IS BEING UNCOOPERATIVE.
THEY ARE TEACHING THINGS THAT
REALLY SHOULDN'T BE TAUGHT IN
THE CLASSROOM.
THEY ARE TREATING YOUR KID
DIFFERENT BASED ON COLOR, YOU
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO GO TO
THE PRINCIPAL AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT, AND IF THAT
DOESN'T WORK, YOU REALLY SHOULD
LOOK INTO ELECTING A MUCH BETTER
SCHOOL BOARD THAT IS GOING TO
SERVE YOUR COMMUNITY BASED ON
MERIT, NOT ON COLOR.
>> Jesse: WHAT KIND OF DAMAGE
TO THE CHILD'S BRAIN DO
SOMETHING LIKE CRT DO?
>> OH, IT IS HORRIFIC.
YOU GET INTO HIGH SCHOOL COURSES
WHERE A TEACHER WILL OPEN THINGS
UP FOR DISCUSSION, AND WE SEE
THIS IN ENGLISH CLASS IS A LOT.
THEY WILL TALK ABOUT A PIECE OF
POETRY ARE SOMETHING THAT A
WRITER HAS BROUGHT TO BEAR, AND
THEN THE TEACHER WILL PORTRAY IT
THROUGH A SOCIETAL LENS LIKE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, AND THEN
PROVIDE THIS ORWELLIAN 2 MINUTES
OF HATE, AND THEN STUDENTS WILL
BE EXPECTED TO TALK ABOUT THINGS
IN THE ESSAY OR IN CASES LIKE
MANHATTAN, STUDENTS WILL BE
EXPECTED TO SAY THINGS FROM HOME
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP IN A VERY
RACIST WAY, AND ALL OF THE
STUDENTS ARE EXPECTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS, TO CHIP IN
A LITTLE BIT OF PROGRESSIVE
IDEOLOGY, AND IT GETS REALLY
SKETCHY REALLY QUICKLY FOR A KID
THAT DOESN'T BUY INTO THE REST
OF THE STUFF.
>> Jesse: AND THEY DON'T DO
THIS IN MATH, DO THEY?
THEY CAN'T BRING CRT INTO MATH,
CAN THEY?
>> OH, THEY SURE CAN.
THEY SURE CAN.
F KNOW MATHEMATICS IS A HUGE
THING COMING TO INDIANAPOLIS
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WE JUST HAD A VERY LARGE MEETING
ABOUT IT AND THERE IS ACTUALLY A
PROGRAM THAT IS BEING DEVELOPED
WITH INDIANA UNIVERSITY THAT
WOULD ANALYZE HOW A TEACHER
TEACHES, ANALYZING THE SCORES
THE STUDENTS, AND THEN
DETERMINE HOW RACIST A TEACHER
IS IN TEACHING THAT MATH COURSE.
>> Jesse: ETHN